It used to be that if you wanted to gamble, you had to go to a casino or racetrack to do it. But the expansion of online gambling and newly loosened laws around sports betting mean that people can now place bets from just about anywhere. Unlimited gambling opportunities are just a few clicks away on your smartphone. Now psychologists and other researchers are investigating whether that increased access could lead to an increase in problem gambling. Gambling disorder is the only behavioral addiction recognized in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. Do new opportunities for gambling mean that more people are at risk of developing it?
过去，如果你想赌博，必须去赌场或赛马场。但在线赌博的扩张以及围绕体育博彩新放宽的法律意味着，人们现在几乎可以从任何地方下注。无限的赌博机会在你的智能手机上只需点击几下即可获得。现在，心理学家和其他研究人员正在调查这种增加的触达是否会导致问题赌博的增加。赌博障碍是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中唯一认可的行为成瘾。赌博的新机会是否意味着更多的人面临患病的风险？
And who is at risk? Are there demographic personality or other factors that make people more likely to develop a gambling addiction? What treatments are available and what are the barriers people face in accessing treatment? What role does stigma play? And what will it mean that explains? to gambling is increasing not just for adults, but also for kids via sports, betting ads, and gambling in video games. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday
谁面临风险？是否存在人口统计学、人格或其他因素，使人们更有可能对赌博上瘾？有哪些治疗方法，人们在获得治疗时面临什么障碍？污名化起到了什么作用？不仅对成年人，而且对儿童来说，通过体育、博彩广告以及电子游戏中的赌博，赌博的接触率都在增加，这将意味着什么？欢迎收听“心理学说话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们有两位嘉宾。首先是罗格斯大学杰出教授兼赌博研究中心主任莉亚·瑙尔（Leah Naur）博士。她是一名临床医生兼律师，专攻赌博障碍和其他行为障碍。她的研究重点是网络赌博和电子游戏、体育博彩、赌博和游戏障碍的原因及治疗，以及与赌博相关的政策问题。她是全国问题赌博委员会董事会成员兼研究委员会主席，并获得了该组织2019年研究奖和2022年终身研究奖。她撰写了多项关于负责任赌博的政策倡议，并联合主编了《威利·布莱克韦尔失调赌博手册》。
life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Leah Naur, a distinguished professor and director of the Center for Gambling Studies at Rutgers University. She's a clinician and attorney who specializes in gambling disorder and other behavioral disorders. Her research focuses on online gambling and video gaming, sports wagering, the causes in treatment of gambling and gaming disorder, and gambling-related policy issues. She's a member of the board of directors and chairs the Research Committee of the National Council on Problem Gambling and won that organization's 2019 Research Award and its 2022 Lifetime Research Award. She's authored several policy initiatives regarding responsible gambling and co-edited the book, The Wiley Blackwell Handbook of
接下来的嘉宾是内华达大学拉斯维加斯分校心理学助理教授兼行为成瘾实验室主任肖恩·克劳斯（Shane Krause）博士。他是一名持证临床心理学家，也是行为障碍（包括赌博障碍）的专家。他研究导致成瘾行为和其他共患病发展的因素，特别是在高危群体中，例如退伍军人。他还在探索识别问题赌博人群的有效筛查方法。非常感谢两位今天做客节目。非常感谢。
Disordered Gambling. Next is Dr. Shane Krause, an assistant professor of psychology and director of the behavioral addictions lab at the University of Nevada, Las Vegas. He's a licensed clinical psychologist and an expert in behavioral disorders, including gambling disorder. He studies the factors that contribute to the development of addictive behaviors and other co-occurring disorders, especially in at-risk groups such as military veterans. He's also exploring effective screening approaches for identifying people with problem gambling. Thank you both for joining me today. Thank you so much.
谢谢。让我们首先为听众提供一些背景信息，了解过去十年左右赌博环境是如何变化的。我提到过，它比以往任何时候都更容易获得。瑙尔博士，你能先给我们简单讲讲为什么会这样吗？哪些法律发生了变化，还发生了哪些其他变化，使得赌博更容易接触到？可能主要的改变是推翻了PAPSA（《专业与业余体育保护法》），这是一项禁止……我的意思是，它做了很多事情，但它在2018年禁止了体育博彩。
Thank you. Let's start by giving listeners some context about how the landscape around gambling has changed in the last decade or so. I mentioned it's more available than ever. Dr. Naur, can you start by telling us briefly about why that is? What loss have changed and what other changes have? occurred to make gambling easier to access? Probably the major change has been overturning PAPSA, which was a law that prohibited, I mean, it did a lot of things, but it prohibited sports wagering in 2018.
作为对这一改变的回应，在新泽西州之后，新泽西州成为第一个真正开始合法化在线体育博彩的州，紧随内华达州之后，但许多其他州也纷纷效仿。四年前，新泽西州也是率先启动在线赌场赌博的州之一，这处于一个更模糊的领域，并没有得到各州那么多的采用。但这些事情确实向几乎所有人开放了通过智能手机接触赌博的便利。那么我们来谈谈问题赌博。我在引言中提到，赌博成瘾是《诊断与统计手册》中列出的唯一行为成瘾。这意味着什么？什么是行为成瘾，它与其他成瘾有何不同？克劳斯博士，
And in response to that, New Jersey was the first state to actually, after Nevada, to actually start legalized online sports wagering, but a lot of other states have followed suit. Four years prior, New Jersey was one of the states that also initiated online casino gambling, which is in a murkier area and hasn't had as much uptake from the states. But those things have really opened accessibility to pretty much everyone from their smartphone. So let's talk about problem gambling. I mentioned in the introduction that gambling addiction is the only behavioral addiction listed in the diagnostic and statistical manual. What does that mean? What's a behavioral addiction and how is it different from other addictions? Dr. Krauss,
我们先从你开始谈这个问题。好的，谢谢。所以我想，如你所知，赌博障碍是一种行为成瘾。物质使用……我认为这是在多年前的2013年确立的，当时赌博从病理性赌博转变为赌博障碍，这归功于非常出色的学术研究识别了这些问题，或真正表明这是一种成瘾行为。我认为，之所以它是一种成瘾或类似成瘾，是因为其标准包括渴望、追逐损失、无法控制自己、经历许多后果。你知道，我们在成瘾行为或物质使用障碍中看到的许多相似之处，虽然有一些微小的差异，但其核心症状是
let's start with you on that one. Yeah, sure. Thank you. So I think, so as you know, gambling disorder is a, is a behavioral addiction. Substance use, I think this came through, you know, many years ago in 2013 when gambling was, went from pathological gambling to gambling disorder because of a really great scholarship and research kind of identifying those issues or really showing that it was addictive behavior. I think that it makes the reason it is an addiction or similar is because of the criteria are things like craving, loss chasing, failure to control oneself, really experiencing a lot of consequences. You know, many of the similarities that we see with addictive behaviors or substance use disorders, there's some slight differences, but really the hallmark symptoms are
相似的。这一点已经通过非常好的纵向研究、临床工作和研究得到了证明，这些研究表明赌博是一种成瘾性障碍，具有非常相似的模式。而行为成瘾是指你不需要将物质摄入体内就能对身体产生改变或影响。在这种情况下，赌博本身会对你的身体以及你的生活产生深远的改变，特别是在它成为问题的时候。所以我想这就是这些变化。目前，赌博障碍是DSM-5 TR中唯一的行为成瘾。
similar. And that's been shown through really good longitudinal work, clinical work, research demonstrating that very similar patterns that gambling is an addictive disorder. And a behavioral addiction is just something that you don't have to ingest the substance in your body to have a change or an impact to your body. And in this case, gambling itself can have profound changes to your body as well as to your life, particularly when it's problematic. So I think that's kind of the changes. And right now, gambling disorder is the only behavioral addiction for DSM-5 TR.
那么关于治疗。因此，如果你在fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）机器中观察有赌博成瘾问题的人的大脑，例如，它看起来会像对甲基苯丙胺（冰毒）等物质成瘾的人的大脑吗？好的。是的。所以我想说，
so for treatment. So if you were to look at the brain of somebody with a gambling addiction problem in an fMRI machine, for example, would it look like the brain of somebody who is, say, addicted to methamphetamine? Okay. Yeah. So I would, yeah. What I would say is that there are differences, but there are greater similarities in how
我想说的是，它们之间存在差异，但在我们思考大脑中的多巴胺或D3受体时，线索或反应的方式有更大的相似性。我认为有一部分，物质使用和赌博之间的通路看起来很相似。这也是它被重新分类的原因之一。所有物质由于其通路及在大脑中的反应方式都略有不同。所以我们不能说它们完全相同，但在某种程度上它们是相似的。从神经生物学的角度来看，核心要素是相似存在的，这也是它被重新分类的原因。将其重新分类为成瘾行为的众多原因之一。
cues or reactions or when we think about the, there's a dopamine or D3 receptor in the brain. I think there's a piece, the pathway looks similar between substance use and scambling. And it's actually one of the reasons it was reclassified. All substances are slightly different because of the pathway and how they react in the brain. So we can't say they're the same, but they're similar in a sense. The core ingredients, I would say from a neurobiological perspective are similarly there, which is why it was reclassified. One of the many reasons it was reclassified is addictive behavior.
因此，有赌博问题的人对线索或赌博线索、彩票、老虎机的反应，他们大脑中的反应以及它被点亮的方式，可能与那些看到线索的物质使用者相似。所以有点不同，但也足够相似，可以说明，是的，这支持了大脑中关于成瘾的生物学机械关系。瑙尔博士，请问，我们是否知道赌博的普及率增加是否真的导致了患赌博障碍人数的增加，还是说现在研究人员下结论还为时过早？对于这一波体育博彩浪潮来说，现在下结论还为时过早。然而，我们所知道的是，我以我所在的新泽西州为例，赌博机会更多的地区，其比率也更高。例如，新泽西州的高风险问题赌博率是6%，是上一项全国流行病学研究公布的全国平均水平的三倍。情况是这样的：随着可用性的增加，人们的接受度和触随着之增加。随着时间的推移，越来越多的人开始参与，这意味着那些会习惯并发展成问题的极小比例人群也在增长。但这是一个较慢的过程。在全国范围内，我们可能还要等五到十年才能看到这一点。我完全同意这种说法，我100%同意这个回答。我认为当我们观察其他物质使用障碍和其他事物时，当我们增加对某些事物的获取途径时，我们通常会看到障碍或问题使用增加的模式。只是这不是立竿见影的。
So how someone experiencing a problem gambling might react to a cue or a gambling cue, a lottery, a slot machine, those reactions in their brain and how it lights up are similar to maybe someone who has substance use, who sees cues as well. So a little different, but also similar enough to say, yes, this is support for kind of a biological mechanistic relationship in the brain here for addiction. Dr. Nauer, let me ask you, do we know whether the increased availability of gambling, is actually leading to an increase in people developing gambling disorder, or is it still too soon for researchers to tell? It's too soon for this particular wave of sports wagering. However, what we do know is areas, and I'll use New Jersey where I am as an example, that have a lot more gambling opportunities, have higher rates. For example, our rate of high risk problem gambling in the state of New Jersey is 6%, which is three times what the last prevalence
这是一个缓慢的、缓慢开始的过程。我认为我们目前在系统层面缺乏的是针对赌博、体育博彩等事物的流行病学或基于流行率的研究。我认为我们确实没有，我认为我们在内华达州有一些趋势。我们收集的数据也显示了一些趋势。但我认为我们真的需要密切关注这一点，因为正如刚才所讨论的，我们不想等到五年后，
national prevalence study said was the rate for the country. And what happens is as you have more availability, you have more acceptability and more accessibility. Over time, more and more people take it up, which means that very small percentage of people that are going to habituate and develop problems also grows. But it's a very, it's a slower process. We're not going to see this nationwide for, you know, another five to ten years. I would absolutely just agree that that's absolutely, I agree 100% with that response. I think when we look at other substance use disorders and other things, when we increase access to things, we generally see a pattern of increase of disorder or problematic use. It's just not immediate.
然后突然说，哦，我们有一些担忧。考虑到体育博彩的广泛扩张（目前已扩展到38个州，而一两年前是31个州），我认为等待的时间太长了。它正在急剧增加。问题赌博的最大风险因素是什么？是否存在人口统计学变量、人格特质或其他使人面临更高风险的因素？我的意思是，有很多病因学因素，这是我们团队经常研究的课题，例如童年虐待、虐待、忽视、创伤暴露、经历创伤。存在某些人格变量，例如较高的高冲动性和冒险性。缺乏积极的压力应对方式，以至于某些子群体的个体利用赌博来帮助自己应对压力。然后还有代际家庭建模这一块。
It's a slow kind of slow start. And I think what we are lacking right now systematically is epidemiological or really prevalence-based research for these, for gambling, for sports wagering, things like. that. I think we really don't have, I think we have some trends here in Nevada. We also have some trends with data we're collecting as well. But I think we really need to be really looking at this because we don't want to wait five years from now, as just discussed. And then suddenly we go, oh, we have some concerns here. That's kind of too long, I think, to really wait, given the wide expansion of sports betting, which is now in 38 states. And a year ago, two years ago, is 31. So it's drastically increasing. What are the biggest risk factors for
因此我们做过的一项研究确实表明，除了其他物质外还接触过赌博的人，不仅会增加该行为的频率，还会增加其他成瘾行为的频率。这进而导致更高水平的问题赌博严重程度。因此，你在家里看到什么以及你在童年时期参与什么，对你年龄增长后的行为模式有很强的预测作用。是的。我会说，在军队中的工作，你知道，我们知道这是一个风险群体，我们看到与创伤史和童年经历以及创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、当前创伤、多次部署、心理健康问题增加等因素之间存在强劲、稳健的联系。所以赌博障碍，
problem gambling. Are there demographic variables or personality traits or other things that put people at a higher risk? I mean, there's a lot of ideological factors, which is something that our group studies a lot of, childhood maltreatment, so abuse, neglect, exposure to trauma, experiencing trauma. There's certain personality variables like higher rates of impulsivity and risk-taking. There's a lack of active stress. coping styles such that certain subgroups of individuals use gambling to help them cope restress. And then there's also this intergenerational family modeling piece.
不幸的是，它往往与其他行为或其他问题同时发生。它并不是孤立发生的。所以我想我们看到了类似的联系。不过，我想说的是，对于我们实验室也正在涉足这一领域的体育博彩和体育博彩活动，我们发现了一些针对30岁以下年轻男性的信号。我认为有一些人口统计学特征是我们需要认真考虑的。其中一部分是技术。
So one study that we did really sort of showed that people that were exposed to gambling in addition to other substances, they would increase their frequency, not just of that behavior, but of other addictive behaviors. And that then led to higher levels of problems. gambling severity. So what you see at home and what you participate in as a child, very predictive of your patterns as you get older. Yeah. And I would say that work in military, you know, we know a risk group, we see strong, robust relationship with exactly trauma history and childhood as well as PTSD, current trauma, many deployments, increased levels of mental health, other issues. So gambling disorder,
谁在使用这项技术进行赌博？我认为其中一些技术可能更多地被年轻群体使用。这不一定是坏事。但安全保障在哪里？我们如何确保关键的年轻人不会发展成问题？这也是我们在文献中发表和发现的内容。所以我确实认为我们需要针对我们正在参与的在线活动思考这些问题。我不知道我们是否已经有了所有这些答案。
unfortunately often co-occurred with other behaviors or in other issues. It does not happen in isolation. So I think we see similar relationships. I would say, though, for sports betting and sports wagering that we're doing kind of our work is our labs also doing some work in this area. I think we're getting signals of younger under 30 male. I think there are some demographics that we need to be thinking about. And part of that is a technology.
我认为确实如此。对于新兴成年人群体，我们刚刚获得了卓越中心资助，用于在一项全国流行病学研究中调查赌博的新兴成年人。因此，我们将能够判断赌博合法化的州与赌博较少的州相比，其发生率是否存在差异。这可能会很有趣。也可能不会，这可能不像我们想象的那样是一个主要的驱动因素。克劳斯博士，我知道你的部分研究是关于开发赌博障碍的有效筛查方法的。目前在初级保健医生办公室或其他环境中进行了多少筛查，
Who's using the technology for gambling? And I think some of these technologies might be more used by younger populations. And that's not necessarily a bad thing. But what are the safeguards? How do we look at to make sure we don't have a problem developing for critically younger people? And this is what we're publishing and finding in our literature as well. So I do think we need to be thinking about these issues for online activity that we're. I don't know that we have all those answers yet.
有效的筛查是什么样的？好的。简短的回答，第一个回答是，还不够，对吧？所以这并不令人惊讶。哦，天哪，真的没有多少。我认为确实没有多少标准化的筛查。我认为你可以进行筛查。所以我们几年前在退伍军人事务部（VA）以及退伍军人医疗保健和初级保健中做过一项研究。
I think that's true. I think with the emerging adult population, we just got the. Center of Excellence grant to look at emerging adults who gamble in a national prevalence study. So we're going to be able to tell whether or not there's higher rates in states that are gambling involved versus those that have less gambling. It might be interesting. It may not be, that may not be as much of a driver as we think it is. Dr. Krause, I know that part of your research is on developing effective screening methods for a gambling disorder. How much screening is done now in places like primary care doctors, offices, or other settings, and what does
我们表明，你可以使用三个项目的筛查工具进行筛查，非常有效，而且我认为筛查不需要花费大量时间。我的意思是，你可以在一两分钟内在初级保健中进行筛查。问题在于，我们没有与医疗服务提供者、心理健康提供者以及人们就问题赌博展开对话。这就是为什么我们称其为隐蔽的流行病或隐蔽的问题、隐蔽的成瘾。所以我觉得真的没有标准化的筛查。我认为有些组织，例如退伍军人事务部（VA），正在积极推行更标准化的筛查。
effective screening look like? Yeah. So I think the short answer, the first answer is that there's not enough, right? So I'm not surprising. Oh, my gosh, there's really not a lot. I think there's just really not a lot of standard screening. I think you can screen. So we did a study a number of years ago in VA and veterans health care and primary care.
这是我们正在做的很多工作。这是一个为1000万患者服务的群体。所以从我的角度来看，如果我要做出重大改变，我将在全国最大的医疗保健机构中实现它。我认为这些是我们正在取得的进展。而且我们已经建立了有效的筛查工具。简要生物社会赌博筛查器（BBGS）非常好。所以我想有有效的方法，但让人们投入并意识到，
And we show that you can screen three items screeners, very effective and could be I don't think it takes a lot of time to screen. I mean, you can be screening in primary care in one or two minutes. The issue is we're not having conversations with medical providers, mental health providers, with people around problem gambling. This is why we call the hidden epidemic or the hidden issue, hidden addiction. So I think there really isn't standardized screening. I think some organizations, the VA, for example, Veterans Affairs, I think is really embracing more standardized screening.
哇，我需要像筛查酒精、抑郁、自杀一样筛查病人的赌博问题。鉴于患有赌博障碍的人在真正遇到许多严重问题（无论是法律问题还是其他问题）并获得帮助之前，往往会经历10年、20年，这应该是一项年度筛查，对吧，很好。你如何克服人们倾向于说谎的习惯？我的意思是，如果你把房子都输光了，你会有强烈的羞耻感。那么，你如何对那些不会对你讲真话的人进行筛查呢？所以，退伍军人们，肖恩的团队，他们在提高其群体意识方面做得非常出色。我可以告诉你，在我们正在进行的研究中，我们开发了一种简短的赌博干预措施，被称为“专家干预”（SBIRT），这是一种在医生办公室和其他环境中使用的非常简短的干预措施。我们遇到了完全相同的问题，如果提到“赌博”这个词——肖恩提到了简短生物社会赌博筛查，其中提到了“赌博”一词。因此，我们不得不调整我们所有的材料，首先询问人们的活动情况，只有当他们锁定了这些活动之后，我们才会向他们询问有关赌博的问题，因为赌博是被接受的，但作为一个赌博者也是高度污名化的。那些购买彩票、抽奖券或做其他事情的人会说，“我可不赌博”，因为他们不想给自己贴上那个标签。所以现在，我会说事情的发展阶段，就像
That's a lot of our work that we're doing. It's a group that serves 10 million patients. So from my perspective, if I can make a big change, I'm going to make it in the largest healthcare organization in the country. And I think those are inroads that we're making. And I think we've established effective screening tools. The brief biosocial screening gambling screener is a BBGS is quite good. So I think there are effective ways, but I think getting people to be invested and realize,
50年代的酒精和40年代的香烟一样。我们现在确实处于被美化和污名化的阶段。是的，绝对是这样。
wow, I need to screen my patients for gambling just like I do for alcohol, depression, suicide. It should be an annual screen given that people who have gambling disorder often go 10, 20 years before they get help after they really have had a lot of profound issues, you know, whether legal or, yeah, good, yeah. How do you get past people's tendency to basically lie? I mean, this is something that if, you know, you've lost the house, you're going to be feeling an awful lot of shame. So how can you screen for people who aren't going to tell you the truth? Well, so the veterans, Shane's group, they've done a fabulous job of really raising awareness in their population. I can tell you in the studies that we're doing, we've developed this short kind of gambling, what's called an expert, which is a very brief intervention to use in doctor's offices, you know, other settings. We've had that exact problem where if the word gambling is mentioned, so Shane mentioned the brief biosocial gambling screen, that mentions the word,
是的。这也是我们项目的一部分，即培训护士、医生和治疗师提出这些基本问题。实际上，一旦他们意识到这一点的重要性，情况就发生了变化。当我们发现患有赌博障碍的人时，几乎所有人都处于复发边缘，并且存在由于赌博而未被发现的高风险。他们会说，“哦，当我筛查赌博并发现它时，我可以治疗一个有自杀高风险的人，”突然间就变成，“哦，太棒了。”所以部分原因确实在于这种认知。但我认为这必须从，
gambling. So we have had to adapt all of our materials such that people are asked about activities and only when they're locked into the activities do we then ask them questions about gambling because gambling is acceptable, but it's also highly stigmatizing to be a gambler. And people who buy lottery tickets or buy raffle tickets or whatever will say, well, I don't gamble because they don't want that label on themselves. So right now, I'd say things. are where alcohol was, you know, in the 50s and where cigarettes were in the 40s. We're really in the glamorized slash stigmatized stage right now. Yeah, absolutely.
我们有很多原因需要改变对“在每个州为赌博提供免费治疗”这一态度的看法，正如前面所提到的。这种文化根本不存在。所以。现在是广告时间。你知道你的订阅实际上花掉了多少钱吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花费大约80美元，但实际总额接近200美元。也许你下载一个应用程序只是为了看一部剧，或者你被免费的7天试用吸引，然后就把这事忘得精光。我知道我干过这事。如果你忘记了某些订阅、有不想要的订阅，或者你不确切知道自己每个月花多少钱，那么你需要Rocket Money。Rocket Money是一个个人
Yeah. And that's part of our project was to train, you know, medical nurses and doctors and, you know, therapists just to ask these basic questions. And really, it wasn't that once they realized the importance of it. So when we found identified people with gambling, that almost all of them were sort of recital and had high risk that was unknown due to gambling. And they go, oh, when I screened for gambling and I do find it and I can treat someone who's high risk for suicide, suddenly it was like, oh, and best. So part of it is really that knowledge. But I think it has to happen from,
理财应用程序，它可以在一个地方查找并取消你不想要的订阅、监控你的支出并帮助你降低账单。Rocket Money将快速轻松地为你查找订阅，对于任何你不想再付款的订阅，只需点击取消，Rocket Money就会为你取消。就是这么简单。Rocket Money还帮助你在一个地方管理所有财务，并自动对你的支出进行分类，以便你可以轻松实时追踪预算，并在发现任何异常时收到警报。已有超过300万人使用过Rocket Money，平均每年为每个人节省高达720美元。所以不要再浪费钱了。
there are many reasons we need to change our attitude around, you know, providing free access to treatment for gambling, you know, in each state. And there's really, we have to have changed the culture around gambling, as, as mentioned earlier. It's just not there. So. And now here's a message from our sponsor. Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around $80 a month on subscriptions, but the actual total is closer to $200. Maybe you downloaded an app just to watch one show, or you got lured in by a free seven-day trial, and then you forgot all about it. I know I've done that. If you have forgotten or have unwanted subscriptions, or if you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, then you need Rocket Money. Rocket Money is a personal
访问rocketmoney.com/APA，用简单的方法取消不需要的订阅并管理你的支出。网址是 rocketmoney.com/APA。即 rocketmoney.com/APA。对于那些可能在考虑自己是否购买彩票或在线进行体育博彩的听众来说，患有问题的特征是什么？你怎么知道自己何时越过了界限，从“我只是偶尔赌博，这挺好玩的”变成了“这是一个问题”？
finance app that fines and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Rocket Money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you, and for any you don't want to pay for any more, just hit cancel, and Rocket Money will cancel them for you. It's that easy. Rocket Money also helps you manage all your finances in one place, and automatically categorize your expenses so you can easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. More than 3 million people have used rocket money, saving the average person up to $720 a year. So stop throwing your money away.
所以，你知道，它通常始于全神贯注。你在本该做其他事情的时候却在想着它。然后会出现一些类似于物质成瘾的症状，例如不进行赌博时经历戒断反应，必须用越来越多钱来赌博才能达到同等水平的兴奋感。接下来会出现更严重的症状，例如你意识到自己这样做是为了逃避问题，你失去了工作，你失去了人际关系，你以向其他人寻求财政援助的形式借钱来支付账单。随着时间的推移，症状会越来越严重。然后你开始追逐损失。所以你第二天再去，试图赢回前一天输掉的钱。当你开始看到这些症状堆积起来时，你就知道自己正在朝着障碍的方向跨越这条光谱。
Cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage your expenses the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash APA. That's rocketmoney.com slash APA. RocketMoney.com slash APA. For our listeners who might be thinking about whether they buy lottery tickets or go online and do sports betting, what are the hallmarks of having a problem? How do you know when you've stepped over the line from, you know, I'm just an occasional gambler and this is kind of fun to this is a problem?
是的，绝对是。当我做培训时，我想跳出来说，追逐损失是一个大问题。这通常是一个转折点，当有人说：“哦，我明天还要再去。我知道我能把它赢回来。”对我来说，我总是告诉人们，当你听到这句话时，我要你脖子后面的汗毛立刻竖起来。我认为，是的，我在培训中就是这么字面说的。我认为这是一个大问题。当你输掉的钱超过了你所能承受的范围时，这就是一个转折点。
So, you know, it sort of starts with being preoccupied. You're thinking about it at times you should be doing other things. And then there are some symptoms that parallel substances like experiencing withdrawal when you're not doing it, having to gamble with more and more, you know, money to achieve the same level of excitement. There's also then more serious symptoms like you recognize you're doing this to escape from your problems, you're losing jobs, you're losing relationships, you're borrowing money in the form of bailouts from other people to pay your bills. So as it goes along, the symptoms get progressively. And then you're chasing your losses. So you go back another day to try to recoup the money that you lost the day before. And when you start to see these symptoms sort of pile up, you then know you're kind of moving across this spectrum toward disorder.
你知道，当你输掉输不起的钱时，你才真正遇到了问题。有哪些治疗方法和疗法可用于治疗赌博障碍？它们的疗效如何？我只想说，针对赌博的治疗是有效的。我认为有几个大问题，正如前面提到的，我们在成瘾问题的看法上还停留在50年代、60年代。所以污名化是一个大问题。人们不愿意，他们有很多羞耻感和污名化。如果人们有赌博问题，我们会从道德上判断他们。但如果他们有物质使用问题，我们会说，“哦，是的，这是一种脑部疾病”，我们会稍微多一点宽容。我认为它们都是成瘾。我们不应该有这种差异，我们不应该区别对待。所以我认为人们往往在寻求帮助之前经历了很长时间的挣扎。但如果他们参与治疗，我们知道循证治疗（如认知行为疗法）非常有效。我们知道心理教育是有效的。我们知道小组疗法是有效的。小组治疗，戒赌互助会（Gamblers Anonymous）。我认为重要的是当有人致力于有帮助的治疗时。治疗是有效的，但赌博是一种成瘾。
Yeah, absolutely. When I do trainings, I was just to jump to say that chasing losses is a big one. That's often the turning point when someone's like, oh, I'm going to go back the next day. I know I can win it back. That to me, I always tell people when you hear that, I want the hair in the back of your neck to stand up immediately. I think it's, yeah, that's what I literally say that in trainings. I think that's a big one. It's a turning point when you're losing more money than you can afford.
人们必须知道复发是很常见的。我总是告诉人们，他们会说：“哦，我滑倒了（复发了）。”我说：“哦，谢谢你的诚实。我预料到了这一点。这是挣扎的一部分。”我个人认为，我们的实验室正在寻找更多诸如基于正念的复发预防或更新的术语，帮助人们放慢脚步，与自己的身体建立联系，因为赌博不是凭空发生的。它不是自动的。这是一个过程。
You know, when you're losing money, you can't afford to lose, really is when you're really having issues. What kinds of treatments and therapies are available to treat gambling disorder and how effective are they? I would just say that treatments for gambling work. I think there's a couple big issues, as mentioned, you know, we're kind of in the 50s, 60s, you know, for addictions. how we think about it. So stigma is a big thing. People don't want to, they have a lot of shame and stigma. We morally judge people for gambling if they have an issue. But if they have substance use, we go, oh, yeah, it's a brain disease and we have a little bit more. And I think that they're both addictions. We should not have that differential, you know, we shouldn't make a difference. So I think people often go a long time before getting help. But if they're engaged in treatment, we know evidence-based treatments, cognitive behavioral therapy can be very effective. We knew psychoeducation can be effective. We know groups can be effective. group therapy, gamblers anonymous. I think what matters is when someone's working towards treatment that's helpful. Treatment works, but gambling is an addiction.
所以治疗确实有效，我总是希望人们保持希望，但他们也必须坦白自己有问题并寻求帮助，与人交流。我认为有许多项目会与他们合作。我认为找到起作用的治疗方法很重要，但我们从真正优秀的既定文献中得知，简短的治疗是有效的。所以，有时与刚开始出现一些问题的人进行45分钟的谈话，就能带来深刻的改变，这是一件很棒的事情，相比之下，那些可能已经有多年的问题的人要好得多。我们也在考虑药物治疗，比如像纳曲酮（Naltrexone）之类的标签外用药，并结合心理治疗。所以关键在于根据严重程度和那个人的状态来匹配治疗。我的目标总是让人门在非常早期介入，而不是20年之后，而这两者我都遇到过。但20年之后意味着三次离婚、无家可归、20万美元的债务，通常还有很多问题，而不是他们目前正经历的一些挣扎。让我们现在就把他们联系起来。所以，是的。我也认为识别我之前提到的潜在风险因素很重要，因为我在自己的实践和研究中看到的是这种成瘾的转移，你知道，人们可以接受最好的赌博治疗，但随后他们没有告诉任何人他们已经发展出性成瘾，或者他们在暴饮暴食，所以他们转移了这些 addictions，而这些事情可以追溯到这些病因学风险因素，如创伤、
It is people have to know that relapse is common. I always tell people, they're like, oh, I slipped. And I said, oh, well, thank you for being honest. And I expected that. This is part of the struggle. I think personally, our lab, we're looking more things like mindfulness-based relapse prevention or more kind of newer terms, helping people kind of slow down, connect with their body because gambling just doesn't happen. It's not automatic. It's a process.
冲动性等不同的事情，如果不加以解决，你就会把这个贝壳下的弹珠移到另一个贝壳下。那么个人可以去哪里获得这种有效的治疗？我的意思是，如果大多数初级保健医生甚至没有进行筛查，我也会假设他们也没有进行治疗，但你如何获得有效的治疗？嗯，这因州而异，可悲的是。我的意思是，这归结于美国所缺乏的东西，我知道这不是这个问题的答案，但如果你问的话，我有很多想法。但这因州而异。因此，我仅代表新泽西州发言，因为那是我的居住地。我的意思是，我们拥有最健全的网络之一，就像你在内华达州一样，那里的免费治疗不仅针对有赌博问题的个人，还针对他们的家人。你几乎可以在该州的任何地方获得资源。现在该州已经开始认证整个治疗中心，以便在全州范围内进行多元文化治疗，确保我们能够照顾到不同种族、族裔、性取向的人。
So treatment does work and I always want people to have hope, but they also have to kind of, you know, disclose they have an issue and seek help and talk to someone. And I think there are many programs out there who will work with them. And I think it's important to find the treatment that works, but we know from really good established literature that brief treatments work. So, you know, sometimes a 45-minute conversation with someone who's early in having some issues can make some profound changes and that's a wonderful thing versus someone who might have had issues for many years. We're thinking about medication as well like an off-label medication for like an atrexone or something like that with psychotherapy right. So it's really about matching the treatment based on the
我们有能够顺应人们现状的辅导员。但有些州甚至没有免费治疗。是的。我正想说，我认为如果有人不确定，第一件事，我认为有时可以查看当地的机构，我认为全国问题赌博中心（NCPG）。如果你访问他们的网站，你可以进行搜索，我们可以为你提供一些链接。但是，是的，以内华达州为例，我实际上在该委员会任职，我们每年花费超过200万美元用于问题赌博的免费治疗。内华达州和新泽西州确实在这方面处于领先地位。
severity and where that person's at. And my goal is always get people very early and not 20 years later and I do both. But 20 years later is three divorces, homelessness, $200,000 in debt with often lots of issues rather than they're having some struggles. Let's hook them up right now. And so, yeah. And I also think it's important to identify the underlying risk factors that I mentioned before because what I've seen in my own practice and in my research is this addiction shifting where, you know, people can have the best gambling treatment, but then they're not telling anyone they've developed a sex addiction or they're, you know, they're binge eating to, so they're shifting these addictions and those things go back to these ideological risk factors like trauma,
我认为这应该成为标配。如果一个州将赌博合法化，他们就应该向个人、他们的家人、配偶和成员提供免费治疗，因为赌博会影响配偶、家庭成员和儿童。这是毁灭性的，对吧？我认为内华达州做到了这一点。新泽西州也是如此。其他州也是如此，加利福尼亚州，还有其他州。但这应该是普遍的。如果你要经营任何赌博业务，就应该提供免费治疗。当我们为超级碗周日一天下注150亿美元时，我认为内华达州花费大约200万美元（我甚至会认为我们需要更多的资金）是没有任何借口的，钱是存在的。但我真的认为如果我们跨州这样做，我们寻找的并不是数十亿美元。我的意思是，真的，那里有充足的资金。这真的很不幸。但再次强调，我认为人们如果有保险，他们应该进行搜索。我认为大多数州都有开展问题赌博工作的优质项目，并将把人们联系起来。但是也有一些全国性的组织，如果不确定，他们可以查找
like impulsivity, like these different things that if left unaddressed, you're just going to be, you know, moving the little shill under this shell to the other shell. So where can individuals go to get this kind of effective treatment? I mean, if most primary care physicians are not even screening, I would assume that they're also not not treating, but how do you get effective treatment? Well, it's state by state, sadly. I mean, this goes to, you know, what's lacking in the U.S., which I know is not an answer to this question, but if you ask it, I will, I have a lot of thoughts. But it's on a state by state basis. And so, and I'm just going to speak to New Jersey because that's where I live. I mean, we have one of the most robust networks, as you do in Nevada, where it's free treatment, not just for the person with the individual with the gambling problem, but also their families. you can get resources pretty much everywhere in the state. And now the state has begun certifying whole treatment centers to treat throughout the state multiculturally so that we're making sure we get, you know, people of different races, ethnicities, sexual orientations.
并输入他们的邮政编码，就会立即找到。我们也会发送其中的一些链接，我们也可以在这一期的播客中为听众提供这些链接。是的。而且你要确保你去的任何人都是认证的赌博辅导员。我的意思是，我们这些在该领域进行治疗的人，不得不去收拾那些只受过物质使用咨询培训、对赌博一无所知的人所造成的烂摊子。如今，接触赌博增加的不仅仅是成年人。儿童和青少年也是如此。据我所知，你和赌博研究人员感兴趣的一件事是电子游戏战利盒（loot boxes）。对于不熟悉这个术语的听众来说，
We have counselors who are going to meet people where they are. But some states don't even have free treatment. Yeah. Yeah, I was just going to say, I think if someone, the first thing, I think if someone's not sure, I think sometimes looking at their local place, I think the National Center, I think, for problem gambling, the NCPG. I think if you go to their website, you can search and we can give you some links on that. But, yeah, in Nevada, for example, I'm actually sitting on that board where we spent over $2 million a year for free treatment for problem gambling. And Nevada and New Jersey really lead this way.
什么是战利盒？战利盒有点像奖品。比方说，你的孩子像我的孩子一样，在很小的时候就开始玩Roblox（罗布乐思）。战利盒一直弹出来。你想跳过关卡吗？如果你想要一把特定的剑或特定的物品，你支付一定数量的Robux（罗布乐思币），但通常有一个随机元素，比如你不确定你会得到哪一个，有些值很多钱，它真的能帮到你，而有些则毫无价值。在更高级的游戏、成人游戏中，这些东西可能要花很多钱，然后你可以在二级市场上出售它们，人们花费数千亿美元。这就是赌博，而且孩子们在很小的时候就被战利盒诱导了。
And I think that should be standard. If a state has legalized gambling, they should be offering free treatment to the, individual, their families, their spouses, and their members because gambling affects spouses and family members and children. It's devastating, right? And I think Nevada is something that they do that. And so does New Jersey. Other states as well, California, there are other states as well. But it should be universal. I think if you're going to operate any gambling, there should be free treatment. And when we're, you know, when we're waging $15 billion for Super Bowl Sunday in one day, I don't think there's any excuses that the money's not there when Nevada spends about two
是的，我会这么说。关于其中的一些研究，我认为我们需要更多真正纵向的研究。我们真的必须了解生命早期与成年期发生的事情。但肯定存在一些关系，虽然更多是相关性的但仍然很重要，早期的战利盒在某种程度上预示着或与年轻成年期发展成赌博行为有关，并且这种行为还在继续。这就是为什么拥有这些纵向设计非常重要。我想说，我也带着一个幼儿。
million, which I would argue we need a little bit more money. But I really think if we did this across the states, we're not looking at billions of dollars. I mean, really, there's plenty of funding there. And it's really quite unfortunate for that. But again, I think people, if they have insurance, they should be searching. I think most states have great programs that are doing problem gambling work and will connect people. So, but there's also some national organizations that if they're not sure, they can look
他快九岁了。我总是很惊讶。我们经常旅行。所以我们去了那些游戏机厅。我记得我那个年代的游戏机厅，我是80年代的孩子。我承认这一点。80年代和90年代的游戏机厅与今天大不相同。我们身处其中的许多游戏机厅看起来非常像老虎机或赌博行为。
them up and they can type in their zip code and they'll find it right away. And we'll also send you some of some of them. links as well that we can provide on this podcast as well for folks. Yeah. And you want to make sure that whoever you go to is a certified gambling counselor. I mean, those of us that treat in this field have had to mop up complete messes from people who just are schooled in substance use counseling and don't know a thing about gambling. Now, it's not just adults who have increased exposure to gambling these days. Kids and teens do as well. And one thing I understand that you gambling researchers are interested in is video game loot boxes. Now, for listeners who aren't familiar with this term,
我认为我们在复制这种模式。这对非常年轻的人意味着什么？我们不想恐慌。但与此同时，我们有道德责任去审视这一点。我认为这并没有像应有的那样受到高质量研究的充分关注。是的。你们都做过关于问题赌博和退伍军人的研究。
what are loot boxes? Lute boxes are little sort of prize. So let's say your child like mine begins on robox at a young age. Lute boxes pop up all the time. Do you want to skip levels? you pay a certain amount of robux if you want a particular sword or a particular item but there's usually a chance element to it like you're not sure which one you're going to get and some are worth a lot and it'll really help you and some aren't worth anything and in the more in the higher level games the adult games these things can cost a lot of money and you can then sell them on a secondary market and people spend thousands of dollars and this is gambling with and and children are primed at a very young age for loob boxes.
为什么这是你们特别感兴趣的一个群体？肖恩，你是专家。我想，我认为，这实际上是几年前开始的。当我在马萨诸塞州的贝德福德退伍军人医疗中心时，我在那里创立了第一个行为成瘾诊所。我当时做的更多是门诊。我开始立即接触到这些患有赌博问题的退伍军人。当时，我在强迫性行为和其他领域以及创伤方面做了更多的工作。我当时就想，哇。
Yeah, I would say that. And some of the research, I think we need more really longitudinal research. We really kind of have to understand what's happening early in life course versus adulthood. But there's definitely some relationships, you know, more correlational but still important, that earlier loopbox kind of is kind of somewhat predicting or kind of related to a younger adulthood developing into gambling behaviors, which kind of keeps going. So this is where, you know, having these longitudinal designs are important. I would say I also have a young child.
我意识到，并不是没有——有些像克利夫兰退伍军人医疗中心的希瑟·查普曼（Heather Chapman）博士这样的人，他们在做着了不起的工作，退伍军人医疗中心里也有一些非常优秀的人。但我意识到，哇，这是一个问题。然后我们开始做研究，我说，好吧，让我开始查看病历。让我们开始发表文章。我们发现，天哪，真的有问题，对吧？确实存在一些问题。
He's almost nine. And I'm always surprised. We always travel. So we got those play arcades. And I remember arcades of my, I'm a child of the 80s. I'll just admit that. And the arcades of the 80s and 90s are very different to today. We're in so many of the games and arcades look very much like slot machines or acts of gambling.
他快九岁了。我总是感到惊讶。我们经常旅行。所以我们去过那些游戏机厅。我记得我那个年代的游戏机厅，我是80年代的孩子。我承认这一点。80和90年代的游戏机厅跟现在很不一样。现在的很多游戏和游戏机厅看起来非常像老虎机或赌博行为。
And I think we're kind of mirroring that. And what does that mean for very young people? And we don't want to panic. But at the same time, we have a moral responsibility to be looking at that. And I think that's not necessarily happening as much as it should be. with really high quality research. Yeah. You've both done research on problem gambling and military veterans.
我觉得我们有点在模仿那种模式。这对年轻人意味着什么？我们不想引起恐慌。但同时，我们有道义上的责任去关注这一点。我觉得高质量的研究在这方面的进展并没有应有的那么多。是的。你们两个都对问题赌博和退伍军人做过研究。
Why is that a group you're particularly interested in? Shane, you're the expert. I think I was, I think, you know, it actually just started years ago. When I was at the Bedford VA in Massachusetts, I started the behavioral addiction clinic there, the first one. I was kind of outpatient. And I started immediately getting these gambling veterans with gambling. And at the time, I was doing more of the work in compulsive sexual behavior and other areas and trauma. And I just said, wow.
为什么这是你们特别感兴趣的一个群体？肖恩，你是专家。我想，你知道的，这其实是几年前开始的。当我在马萨诸塞州的贝德福德退伍军人事务部时，我在那里创立了行为成瘾诊所，那是第一家。我当时主要做门诊。我开始立刻接触到这些有赌博问题的退伍军人。当时，我更多地从事强迫性行为、其他领域以及创伤方面的工作。我当时就想，哇。
And I realized there's not as much there are people like Dr. Heather Chapman, who's in Cleveland, VA, who's doing amazing work. And there's some really great folks in the VA. But I realized, wow, this is a problem. And then we started doing the research. And I said, well, let me start looking at the medical records. Let's start publishing. And we found, holy moly, there are problems, right? There really are some issues.
我意识到这方面的研究还不够多，虽然有像克利夫兰退伍军人事务部的海瑟·查普曼博士这样的人在做非常棒的工作，退伍军人事务部里也有一些非常优秀的人。但我意识到，哇，这是一个问题。然后我们开始做研究。我说，好吧，让我开始查看病历。让我们开始发表文章。我们发现，天哪，确实有问题，对吧？确实存在一些问题。
And I think it's that narrative with trauma. I think people go through really difficult things and they cope differently. And I think sometimes it's alcohol and drugs and cannabis and sometimes it's pornography or sexual behavior and sometimes it's gambling. And sometimes these things earlier in our life are not problematic. But when trauma and other mental health is intermixed, they become problematic. And I think veterans, given, have higher rates of trauma and other mental health disorders, depression, anxiety, other things. And, you know, divorces, separations, deployments. When you mix all that in, it's not really surprising.
我认为这就是创伤叙事。人们经历非常困难的事情，他们有不同的应对方式。有时候是酒精、药物和大麻，有时候是色情或性行为，有时候是赌博。有时这些事情在我们生命的早期并不是问题的。但是，当创伤和其他心理健康问题交织在一起时，它们就成了问题。我认为退伍军人由于种种原因，有着更高比例的创伤和其他心理健康障碍，如抑郁、焦虑等。而且，你知道的，离婚、分居、部署。当你把所有这些混合在一起时，其实并不令人意外。
The other thing is that they also have a lot of gambling on overseas bases. Each year of the bases make about $100 million in slot machines, of which none of the revenue goes for treatment or research, which I just want to put that out there, as I always say. So I think doesn't mean that necessarily people at 18, 19, 20 in the military developing a problem, but when they're under stress deployed away from family, we have seen many patients starting to have issues at a young age that continue throughout their once they discharge from the military. So I think we needed to be doing a better job of, you know, preventive and we're not, I think, right now. And the issue is that we see this all over in the VA and our publications demonstrate veterans have high rates of mental health and addictive disorders, including gambling, including pornography, sex, you name it, because I think of the trauma component. I think that's one of the key factors that, you know, has been discussed. I didn't realize that about slot machines on military bases. Is that being supported by our military?
另一件事是，他们在海外军事基地也有大量的赌博活动。这些基地每年从老虎机中获得约1亿美元的收入，其中没有一笔收入用于治疗或研究，我只是想指出这一点，正如我经常说的那样。因此，我认为这并不意味着军中18、19、20岁的人必然会发展成问题，但当他们在远离家人的部署压力下，我们看到许多患者在年轻时就开始出现问题，并在退伍后持续下去。所以我想我们需要在预防方面做得更好，而我们现在认为并没有做到。问题在于，我们在退伍军人事务部（VA）各处都看到了这种情况，我们的出版物表明，退伍军人患有高比例的心理健康和成瘾障碍，包括赌博、色情、性，应有尽有，我认为这是因为创伤因素。我认为这是被讨论的关键因素之一。我以前不知道军事基地里有老虎机。这是受到我们军队支持的吗？
I mean, are they the ones who are doing this or are they outsourcing this to contractors? So it's outsourced, but they, in a sense, it's for the military. It's for recreation and leisure. And they use the money internally on the basis overseas, not in the states. But there's really lack of prevention or education or psychoeducation happening. There's really not a lot of responsible gaming or gambling messaging happening. Yeah. So it's been happening for many years.
我的意思是，是他们在做这件事，还是把这外包给了承包商？所以它是外包的，但在某种程度上，它是为军队服务的。它是为了娱乐和休闲。他们把钱用在海外基地的内部，而不是在美国本土。但确实缺乏预防、教育或心理教育。确实没有发生很多负责任的博弈或赌博的信息传递。是的。所以这种情况已经持续很多年了。
It's kind of a big secret. So whenever I tell people, I do these talks, I go, no way. And I said, oh, yes, yes, way. It's a big deal. A hundred million a year. And not a penny of it goes for treatment or for prevention. And I think give us five million of that hundred million and we can do a lot of good for our military. So, you know, just putting that out there.
这有点像个大秘密。因此，每当我告诉人们时，我做这些演讲，我说，不会吧。然后我说，哦，是的，是的，会。这是一件大事。每年一亿美元。而其中一分钱也没有用于治疗或预防。我认为给我们那一亿里的五百万，我们就能为我们的军队做很多好事。所以，你知道，只是提一下。
Given the laws that we have right now, what's the most important policy change you think could be made to help mitigate the harms and protect people from developing gambling disorder? So this is my huge bandwagon. The federal government needs to take the hands off their eyes, their ears, and their mouth and get involved. The federal government gets enormous amounts of tax revenue from legalized gambling. But unlike in the UK, where there is a federal organization that oversees all these different regulations, et cetera, for gambling to have some uniformity, there is no presence at the U.K. There is no presence at the federal organization. that oversees all these different regulations, et cetera, for gambling to have some uniformity, there is no presence at the federal level. There is no money for, not a dollar for research. People like Shane and me, we have been very entrepreneurial to just stay in this field. A lot of people leave because there's money for alcohol, drugs, everything else, but not gambling.
鉴于我们现在拥有的法律，你认为可以做出什么最重要的政策改变来帮助减轻危害并保护人们免受赌博失调的困扰？所以这是我的核心呼吁。联邦政府需要睁开眼睛、耳朵，闭上嘴巴，参与进来。联邦政府从合法赌博中获得了巨额税收。但与英国不同，英国有一个联邦组织监督所有这些不同的法规等，以便对赌博进行某种统一管理，而美国联邦层面却没有这种存在。联邦层面没有任何组织。没有任何资金，连一美元的研究经费都没有。像沙恩和我这样的人，一直非常积极地维持在这个领域。很多人离开了，因为有针对酒精、毒品和其他一切的资金，但没有针对赌博的。
And there's nobody regulating advertising. There's nobody policing operators are ensuring that there are standards that give the person a fair playing field. It's terrible. And it's my biggest sorrow is that we just have no federal presence. I would just say, yeah, absolutely, I couldn't agree with that more. It's just really, it's just really surprising, too, given the amount of revenue and the expansion of gambling. And you kind of think is kind of a preemptive, well, that's like, let's put some money into the research and prevention. Let's just make sure, you know, let's just spend, you know,
而且没有人监管广告。没有人监督运营商或确保有标准为个人提供公平的竞争环境。这太糟糕了。我最大的悲伤就是我们根本没有联邦层面的存在。我只想说，是的，绝对地，我不能再同意这一点了。这也真的很令人惊讶，鉴于收入的数额和赌博的扩张。你可能会认为这是一种先发制人的做法，比如，让我们把一些钱投入到研究和预防中。让我们确保，你知道，让我们花一些，你知道的，
50 million expand free treatment just to prevent it because we know those with gambling disorder are more likely to kill themselves or more likely to have homeless. Everything you can think of, that's bad news bears, as we say, is good to happen, right? Partly because they go eight to 10 years before they tell someone, so they destroyed their life versus with substance use, if my patients are really actively using for four or five days and I see them, I go, hey, what's going on? I can tell something's up. But with gambling, you can walk to the slot machine or the casino lose $50,000 in a day and I can't tell. So this is why they're difference.
5000万美元来扩大免费治疗以防止它，因为我们知道那些患有赌博失调的人更有可能自杀，更有可能无家可归。你能想到的所有坏消息，正如我们所说的那样，都会发生，对吧？部分原因是因为他们在告诉别人之前经历了8到10年，所以他们摧毁了自己的生活，相比之下，如果是物质使用，如果我的患者真的积极使用了四五天，我看到他们，我会说，嘿，怎么了？我能看出有些不对劲。但对于赌博，你可以走到老虎机或赌场一天输掉5万美元，而我看不出来。这就是它们的不同之处。
But I think with this massive expansion and a lot of revenue, it is really irresponsible at this point. And I think sports betting, the revenue from that is just, I mean, wow, even for me, I'm shocked at how much it is. And yet that isn't being, none of that's going back into kind of a new federal agency or some way regulatory body. And I think it's really irresponsible. And I do think in the next four or five years we're going to really might be paying for it.
但我认为随着这种大规模的扩张和大量的收入，在这个时候这确实是不负责任的。而且我认为体育博彩，那里的收入简直是，我的意思是，哇，甚至对我和我来说，我对它的数额之大感到震惊。然而并没有，没有多少返回到某种新的联邦机构或某种监管机构。我认为这真的很不负责任。而且我确实认为在接下来的四五年里，我们真的可能会为此付出代价。
And that's going to be, you know, and we don't need to be doing cleanup crew five years from now. We need to be preventing people from suffering rather than treating suffering later. I talked to a journalist from the UK and he said, when I look at the U.S., I feel like I'm watching a car crash but can't look away. And I thought that was a beautiful way of capturing it. So what are you both researching now? what are the big questions that you're trying to answer? Dr. Nower, you want to start with that one? So we do all the big data analysis on every bet placed in the state of New Jersey, even online or sports. So we're looking at trends, patterns, problematic play patterns, responsible gambling and harm reduction strategies.
这将是，你知道的，我们五年后不需要做清理工作。我们需要防止人们遭受痛苦，而不是稍后治疗痛苦。我跟一个英国记者谈过，他说，当我看着美国时，我觉得我正在看一场车祸，但又无法把视线移开。我认为这是一个完美捕捉这一现象的绝妙方式。那么你们俩现在都在研究什么？你们试图回答的重大问题是什么？诺尔博士，你想从那个开始吗？所以我们在新泽西州对每一笔下注进行所有的大数据分析，甚至是在线或体育博彩。所以我们正在寻找趋势、模式、有问题的游戏模式、负责任的赌博和减少危害的策略。
We just got this grant from the International Center for Responsible Gaming, a Center of Excellence grant to look at, at gambling among emerging adults. So we're looking at genetics that are paired with these sort of ideological risk factors we've been talking about. We're doing a national prevalence study on emerging adults in highly involved versus lower, moderately involved gambling states. Gosh, we're trying to pilot this brief treatment that we're, that in like health settings, just a few of the things we're doing.
我们刚刚从国际负责任博弈中心（ICRG）获得了这个资助，一个卓越中心资助，用于研究新兴成人的赌博行为。所以我们正在研究与我们一直在讨论的这种病因学风险因素相配对的遗传学。我们正在对处于高度参与和较低、中度参与赌博州的年轻成年人进行全国患病率研究。天哪，我们正试图在医疗环境中试行这种简短的治疗，这只是我们正在做的几件事情中的一部分。
We're doing lots of stuff. Dr. Krause, what about you? Oh, same here. We're doing lots of stuff. So I think some of the big things we're doing with VA, so we're looking here, working with our local VA here. And this is Nevada, Southern Nevada healthcare system here. And we're looking at treatment. So we're looking at kind of psychopharmacology, in this case, Vivitrol or Nautroxone, with co-occurring substance use and gambling. Is that helpful?
我们正在做很多事情。克劳斯博士，你呢？哦，彼此彼此。我们也在做很多事情。所以我认为我们正在对退伍军人事务部（VA）做的一些重大事情，所以我们在这里看着，与我们这里的当地退伍军人事务部合作。这就是内华达州，内华达州南部医疗保健系统。我们正在研究治疗。所以我们正在研究心理药理学，在这种情况下，维维曲（Vivitrol）或纳曲酮（Naltrexone），用于共病物质使用和赌博。这有帮助吗？
We're also looking at mindfulness-based relapse prevention broadly for gambling, including substance use. It's been shown to be effective. We've published, you know, kind of a pilot on that, but we want to explore that. We're also doing some community-based work here, trying to understand really actually getting great data here in our community around barriers to care, why people don't get help in our community. Why? Because we know our population about it's growing and how do we increase Spanish-speaking services, lots of things. We really need to adapt. And so I think that's that.
我们还在广泛研究基于正念的戒复发预防用于赌博，包括物质使用。这已被证明是有效的。我们已经发表了，你知道，关于这方面的初步试验，但我们想进一步探索这一点。我们还在这里做一些基于社区的工作，试图了解，实际上在我们的社区中获得了关于护理障碍的很好的数据，为什么人们在我们的社区中没有得到帮助。为什么？因为我们知道我们的人口在增长，以及我们如何增加西班牙语服务，很多事情。我们真的需要适应。所以我想就是这样。
Just doing a lot of, we also have sports wagering. ICRG has funded a grant. We're on year two now with my colleague, Dr. Joshua, jobs, University of New Mexico, and we're looking at, we're getting the fourth wave of data longitudinally on sports betting. So we're going to be hoping to look at risk factors for sports betting as well or wagering, particularly within groups, because we really need longitudinalal and kind of these epidemiological, you know, people say, well, how bad is it? And I don't know. And I don't know that like, like in Nevada, it's kind of amazing. Nevada hasn't had a prevalence
做很多事情，我们也有体育博彩。ICRG资助了一项拨款。我和我的同事约书亚·乔布斯博士（新墨西哥大学）现在已经是第二年了，我们正在寻找，我们正在获得关于体育博彩的第四波纵向数据。因此，我们希望也能寻找体育博彩或下注的风险因素，特别是在群体内部，因为我们真的很需要纵向的数据以及这些流行病学的数据，人们会说，情况有多糟？我不知道。我不知道，就像在内华达州，这有点惊人。内华达州还没有过患病率
study. And over 20 something years, yet our population's tripled and, you know, our revenue is up. And it's great. It's a lot of positive things for Nevada. But yet, we don't, we need a prevalence. We need true accurate prevalence to understand our community and risk factors for a lot of people. So we don't have that. So that's what those are things we're working on. Well, this is all really interesting. I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think you've given us a lot of good information and I hope our listeners will find it useful. Thank you. Thank you so much. You can learn more about psychologists' research on gambling in the July issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.apa.org slash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeatingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
研究。在过去的20多年里，然而我们的人口增加了两番，你知道，我们的收入上升了。这很好。对内华达州来说有很多积极的事情。但是，我们没有，我们需要一个患病率。我们需要真实准确的患病率来了解我们的社区和很多人的风险因素。所以我们没有这个。所以这些就是我们正在努力的事情。好吧，这一切都非常有趣。我要感谢你们今天加入我。我认为你们给我们提供了很多很好的信息，我希望我们的听客会觉得它有用。谢谢。非常感谢。你可以在APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）7月号上了解更多关于心理学家对赌博研究的信息。请访问www.apa.org/monitor。你可以在我们的网站www.w.combeatingof psychology.org上找到《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的剧集，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us. us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件。我们的邮箱是Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学说话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪扬（Chris Kondyian）。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。